everybody glad you came back so we got
to freak out about this arrow finale
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet and I will talk about Titan
Deathstroke stuff in the video - hey kid
glad you came back I know there's all
kinds of questions based on that crazy
cliffhanger but I'll say new round of
the flash ring giveaway starts now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
they're leaving all that big stuff for
season 6 episode 1 so we don't know what
the title for that is yet but obviously
most of that episode is going to be the
rest of this story sort of like a
two-hour episode just stretched over the
finale and the premiere for next year
but don't worry arrows coming back
pretty much the same time it comes back
every year but being things first we got
to freak out about Deathstroke kicking
all that ass the way Prometheus ended
the episode I think it's a fitting end
for his character and it answers exactly
what happened now there are a couple of
characters that you think may have died
off-screen but remember until you see a
body it's not over it really the only
exception I think to that is prometheus
because Oliver was standing there
watching him do it the only reason they
didn't show that is because this is the
CW network and little kids watch this TV
show they're not going to show that to a
bunch of little kids like you have one
standing right here William is
witnessing all this happen even though
his eyes are shut he's going to have to
deal with the trauma this this is how
superheroes are made in tragedy like
this super villains - but we can all
speculate on what Williams going to
become some day in the future of
whatever fiction this show is created so
a whole bunch of Easter eggs calling
back to season 1 to the comics let's
start top 10 welcome back Deathstroke
glad you came back kid there's so much
exposition in this opening scene about
Deathstroke's character what's been
happening to him while he's been in
prison this whole time since I think
season 3 was the last time we saw him in
what the terms of him helping Oliver out
now part of it he's doing out of his
guilt for the things that he's done but
the real carrot that Oliver dangles is
helping Slade find his son Joseph so
Slade actually has three children in the
comics I don't know if we'll ever meet
the other ones on this show because
we've seen Grant so if you haven't read
Teen Titans they're all big Teen Titans
DC Comics characters with their own sets
of powers Joseph is the one that the TV
show is mentioned his comic-book name is
Jericho he has powers of mind control
they had that animated movie they just
released Teen Titan
Judis contract he's a big part of that
he's mostly known as a good character
this is the new 52 look for his
character but for most of Teen Titans
this is what he looked like because of
his power he winds up getting used by
Trigon Ravens father so it's this big
thing that arrow is probably never going
to get into so I'm not expecting Jericho
on arrow anytime soon but a lot of that
gets into what they're doing with the DC
Teen Titans TV shows that Geoff Johns is
writing that's going to premiere next
year on that DC streaming service so
I'll try to address that later in the
show because I think that arrow largely
has claimed of the Deathstroke Manu
Bennett version of the character we
don't know if he's going to be the
Deathstroke of the Titans TV show or if
they're going to recast someone else
they could choose to go either way it
depends on how connected to the arrow
verse the new Titans show is going to be
Slade explains that the mirakuru
completely out of his system he is fully
in control of his mental faculties so he
is much closer to the early season 2
version before he got the mirakuru went
completely crazy and started coming
after Oliver because of shado
but they do name-drop her a couple times
as they're walking across the island
reminds me of old times kid but number 9
Captain Boomerang double crosses them so
you know ever since the season 3 arrow
flash crossover he's been in that prison
so they let him out to help but turns
out that Prometheus got to him first
offered him a better deal
we didn't offer the deal to use Slade
because we knew you probably wouldn't be
interested that's important if you're
not fully familiar with the Deathstroke
character it just sort of sets up the
idea that he has a code he's going to be
honorable and he has history with Oliver
in Captain Boomerang does not he hates
Oliver he's a total douchebag he's kind
of a douche bag in the Suicide Squad
movie that just who the character is
digger Harkness will double-cross anyone
he has no honor
so they free everyone there's a lot of
funny back and forth everybody's
commenting on Deathstroke I love the way
that team arrow reacts to destro
seriously he killed your mother you set
him free Nyssa and Merlyn had a lot of
great scenes like that they even
reference getting rid of the League of
Assassins but a lot of these midway
scenes are just setting up a lot of the
conflicts they're trying to resolve in
the episode so number 7 Deathstroke
explains Oliver's true problem his guilt
over his father's death you blame
yourself for your father's shooting
himself and everything bad that's
happened
since then you gotta let that go kid you
gotta learn to live with it but you got
to put it behind you so dead stroke is
also kind of talking about himself to
all the terrible stuff that he's done he
feels like he's in a much more Zen state
right now so number six it's all set up
for Merlin also trying to do the same
thing put the past behind him make
amends with Tia for all the bad things
that he's done like she says he
manipulated me into killing our best
friend and that was all the way back I
think during the first two episodes of
arrow season 3 that was a long time ago
I haven't thought about that in a while
but then proceeds to sacrifice himself
or try to sacrifice himself when Thea
steps on the landmine so here's the
important thing a lot of people were
messaging me about this on Twitter
didn't Merlyn die off screen because you
know everybody blew up at the end of the
episode so it's like they're alive
aren't they yes unless you see a body
they're not dead so like I said the
beginning of the video a very important
concept in comic book TV shows and comic
books in general just look at the smirk
on Merlin's face as Captain Boomerang
walks up and he's like what you know
what's going on here why are you
standing here in Merlyn smiles a little
bit and you see the explosion from
Thea's perspective so all that she knows
is that the mind went up she doesn't
know anything about Captain Boomerang
showing up but think about Merlyn what
is his nick name he's Merlin the
magician so what they're doing is his
John Barrowman said that he's not coming
back for arrow season 6 when he could be
lying just to heighten the surprise oh
my god did he actually die make you
wonder but - I also think it's just
because he's not going to be featured in
a ton of episodes we're going to make
you ride the bench we've been using you
a little bit too much so we're going to
cycle in some other new characters but
if there's any doubt 100% I think that
he is still alive to come back and do
something in the future season if it's
not going to be the first episode of
season 6
I think they'll answer a little bit more
about what's going on with Captain
Boomerang in a Captain Boomerang survive
then Merlin probably survived - so just
do not worry they're not going to kill
really big comic book characters like
that off screen they would at least let
you see that happen like when they
killed Katie Cassidy the first time you
actually saw it happened you saw like
the life slowly fade from her so you
knew that she was dead
number 5 though dead stroke double
crossing like a pro I love the way he
just punches Oliver out on a
but they all planned it in advance I
knew that Slade was going to do that but
later they revealed that Oliver set it
up with him I was actually kind of
hoping that Slade which is going to call
an audible and Oliver wouldn't know
about it so he'd be like hey why'd she
hit me why'd you have to do that oh well
I was just trying to maneuver us into
this situation so it was all just a ruse
to get Dinah that sonic device so that
she could get her canary cry back and
they could free themselves the
interesting thing about this monastery -
it looks really cool but Oliver said
that he's never been inside it we've
seen maps of the island before but
there's this idea that it's so big that
Oliver's never been to every single inch
of it so they can always surface new
places but part of me does wonder if
they blew it up at the end does that
mean that we're not going to go back
there I think that we'll always go back
to the island in some way but I think
they just want to let you know that
they're blowing it up so that we're not
going to be seeing it all the time
during season six but number four team
arrow vs. team prometheus so you have
Nyssa versus Talia totally awesome fight
I love the way they talk about their
history - there's a lot of exposition in
their fight you abandon me to a father
that never loved me you dissolve the
League of Assassins father was never
going to pass the mantle of leadership
to a woman so you get that really
awesome canary on canary moment I love
Quentin - he's really backing the new
Dinah they call her the canary and he
corrects them it's Black Canary and then
just knocks out Katie Cassidy no trust
me I really needed to do that so I am
really wondering what she's going to be
doing is a series regular in season six
so like the main villain of season six
is supposed to be called the Covenant
maybe she'll be working with them
because it sounds like there'll be a
really big presence but if she's going
to be a series regular that means she's
going to be in most episodes then all
these scenes of Deathstroke just mowing
through all of Talia's League meant this
is so much fun so I know a lot of people
were like wait is Deathstroke going to
be fighting prometheus no that's always
going to be Oliver that's his fight
Deathstroke is there for crowd control
just because crixus style he can go
berserker rage on all these people but
number three Oliver kills Kovar in the
flashbacks he was trying to keep him
trapped on purgatory he gives him some
pretty good scars to tell people about
when he gets back home but the funny
thing here is that they were walking
through the woods earlier in the episode
in present day they step over a skeleton
that's Kovar skeleton so you're doing
that he died in the flashbacks Oliver
said that he killed him a long time ago
so his fate was sealed it was just a
matter of how it was going to go down
and what that death meant and how it was
going to inform all of his character so
it was all about him being trapped in
purgatory in as Slade explains to him
you know how he's been guilty about the
death of his father this whole time all
the bad things that have happened he has
kind of been trapped in purgatory for
these past five seasons in now he's
slowly getting past that so after he
defeats Prometheus that was what that
big speech was about in present day no
matter what you do I'm never going to
become the man that you want me to
become number two they mirror the scene
on the boat when he hails them with a
big bonfire it's almost shot-for-shot
exactly like it is in the first episode
I kind of wondered if they used any old
footage for this and I think they used a
little bit but most of it they did
reshoot from new angles so I think like
99% of this is brand new because if you
look at the coloring of the pilot
episode everything looks just a little
bit different I think they use a
slightly different camera so it's just a
quicker version of the opening moments
of the pilot any calls Moira and that is
the surprised person that all of our T's
the cameo that he was like I'm so happy
this person came back it means so much
to the episode and you find out why
because he's like crying to his mother
I'm so happy please don't hang up just
listen to my voice did your father
survive too he also says that Sara
didn't survive
remember this version of Oliver at this
point in the timeline didn't know that
she made it off the island and it's just
a great way to end the episode and it
makes me wonder because there's so much
story to tell in episode 1 that finishes
what's going on here after this
cliffhanger if we're going to see more
of this Moira scene or if this was all
of it but number one Oliver rescues his
son off the boat his son finally sees in
broad daylight that he is the green
arrow in prometheus
kills himself setting off all the bombs
on the island so they really want you to
think that the island is no more so even
though I think that will continue to go
back there
I mean if arrow goes for seven seasons
of course they're going to go back to
the island it means so much to the
character it's just them saying that hey
you know we're probably not going to be
coming back here for a while but for
those of you wondering how teen arrow
could survive that they said they were
leaving the plane they were going to the
other side
the island with the Argos supply boat
that's probably near where the
underground prison is and what is the
underground prison if not a concrete
enforced bugger so there were explosions
going off all over the island you would
want to hide in the safest place and
that is the underground prison so let me
know in the comments what did you guys
think about the episode and how do you
think the team arrow survived that
explosion they really want to make you
wonder but I feel like the easiest way
is for them to just climb into the
underground prison biggest moments in
the episode though are probably those
speeches from Deathstroke about being
guilty about the death of his father and
then Prometheus of speech at the end
about William finally learning the truth
of his father the way that Oliver
learned the truth of his father
Prometheus learned the truth of his
father you're going to get to grow up
and be together you'll need each other
it's going to be a long night you know
before he blows everything up there's a
really sinister way of saying something
really nice about how fathers and sons
are really important and I'm hoping that
they do something cool with all of her
son in the future of this show so I'm
not expecting any crazy superhero stuff
just expect William to pop up at least
once per season in some meaningful way
like hey you know coming to visit dad
but what's going to happen next is a
whole bunch of footage dropped obviously
the Game of Thrones trailer happened so
I'm working on my flash season 4 video
I'll post that next then there's more
Game of Thrones there's another
spider-man trailer to drop I'll do a
video for so I'll try to get through
everything but just leave all your DC TV
requests in the comments and I will do
more Titan stuff I'll talk about
Deathstroke the future of that character
what they can do with them on arrow
versus the other shows and all say
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner David rose please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details I will be
doing weekly flash DC TV videos every
week during the break so there's all
kinds of stuff coming this summer it is
going to be awesome so while you wait
for everything click here can re-watch
that Game of Thrones Season 7 trailer
and you can click here for my flash
finale video thank you so much for
watching let's high-five I'll see you
guys tonight
you